the tension in the air was palpable
everyone who sat around the long oak
table was sweating in their business
suits tugging at their ties so that it
might dislodge the collective lumps in
everyone's throats at the head of the
table someone sat facing away from the
rest of the gathered Executives their
silk-loved hands interlocked the crown
of a top hat just visible over the back
of their broad thrawn-like chair so my
friends they said without turning around
in a voice that filled the boardroom
what a sorry State of Affairs this is
the SCP Foundation sticking their noses
in sniffling around the company shutting
down factories and then there are our
customers who obsessed with fortnite to
be interested in the toys we're making
if one detainment Enterprises can't
touch the hearts of every man woman and
child on the planet then what are we
even doing here what is our point a
pause lingered nobody in the room knew
whether to answer or keep quiet and let
somebody else speak first that wasn't a
rhetorical question the voice yelled
from its chair we are a company that
makes toys that is our point and that's
why you're here so go ahead don't be shy
pitch me something after another moment
of silence one of the board members
nervously stood up from his chair
attempting to strain his tie he produced
a box containing a prototype
um I might have something doctor he said
nervously struggling to compose himself
go on opening the box the man produced a
small circular spinning top with Jagged
edges or a Beyblade to those born after
1999. so um 90s Nostalgia is back in
right now the executive stammered
assembling the Beyblade in his shaking
hands and wondertainment Enterprises can
be the first to relaunch this popular
playground craze from uh back in the day
he pulled the rip cord letting the
spinning toy loose on the desk instead
of spiraling in a circle though the
Beyblade shot across the table's surface
and hopped down to the floor a tiny
voice emanating from it the entire time
no no please don't make me fight I can't
I won't do it I don't want to die it's
sobbed as it raced across the floor and
out the door realizing he didn't need to
say anything else the board member sat
back down another stood up more eager
now that somebody else had gone first
well we were thinking something more for
the younger Market she declared she
produced a large flashcard that
displayed an image of a pretty ordinary
looking hobby horse you can't really go
wrong with the classic right she asked
looking around the room for any looks of
approval from the rest of the board
anyway these hobby horses are durable
they come in a range of colors there's
just um
one little caveat we got some calls from
the Italian Prime Minister after we'd
been testing them apparently at the
exact same time someone rocks on one of
these hobby horses a random person in
Italy just gets turned to dust he
currently have uh no way of
counteracting this there were a few
short murmurs from the rest of the board
sensing she was losing them the same
executive signaled her assistant who
retrieved something from outside the
boardroom as she re-entered she was
holding a teddy bear at arm's length
grimacing in disgust the rest of the
board quickly realized why the bear
carried with it a pungent stench that
hung heavy in the air keeping with that
younger Market I was talking about the
exact piped up again holding her nose
shut kids love gross out of humor right
you put a fart in an animated movie and
the Tykes go nuts for it so this
delightful product the stinky bear can
bring the same enjoyment into the home
for the low price of 39.99 althoughs the
same bears that r d was testing a while
back one of the other entertainment
Executives asked the ones that had a one
in five chance of releasing lethal
amounts of novichok it isn't that a
Russian nerve agent another exclaimed in
order gets its stinky bear out of here
defeated the presenting executive retook
her seat while her assistant carried the
bear to the incinerator well this has
been a polo show thus far came the good
doctor's voice from the far end of the
table interrupted by a tinny electronic
beeping Mr Glenridge what is that in
your pocket ah sorry feeding time the
board member Mr Glenridge apologized
pulling out a tiny oval-shaped device
and oddly enough a candy bar it's a
Tamagotchi you remember those right well
we whipped up this one to be more
intelligent but it keeps demanding
actual solid food so I just have to you
know Glenridge then proceeded to tear
open the candy wrapper and began mushing
it into the tamagotchi's LCD screen the
virtual pet made a number of sad
sounding beeps almost like he was crying
over its own lack of taste buds I think
the problem here is obvious a stuff here
older member of the board Mr Omer spoke
up look we all know that the dang kids
are too distracted by their darn cell
phones these days and sure we could sit
here and try to get them interested in
the anomalous entertainment we're trying
to sell them or we could try to profit
off them by going after what we know
they're already obsessed with I really
don't think you should pursue this train
of thought Mr Omer an executive named
mix Clarin interjected no this is a good
idea Homer protested it's simple we
develop an app a video game that the
kids won't be able to get enough of but
here's the catch in order to progress in
that game we can encourage them to spend
real cash in exchange for some kind of
uh virtual currency that can only be
used in the app it'd be essentially
worthless useless even anywhere other
than inside our game but if they want to
be the best at it then the kids will
have to keep coughing over the dough and
hey we could even throw in some kernel
grade spyware too so when they have the
app on their phones it simultaneously
harvests all their personal data and at
the snap of the doctor's glove fingers
Mr Omer was suddenly vaporized letting
off one final shriek as he turned into a
pile of Ash on the table I think Mr Omer
failed to realize that many other
companies already beat us to the punch
with that idea
Dr wondertainment's side exasperated and
besides we aren't monsters somebody else
take the floor please well Nick's Clarin
mumbled standing up wiping some of Mr
omer's Ash off their glasses our social
media team has been doing some research
into Current Online Trends and it turns
out we might have something that fits
with a really popular one Claren
produced a pristine dolls house a
two-scale recreation of a single story
home in Albuquerque New Mexico they
opened up the walls revealing a group of
figurines inside each one moving of its
own accord mimicking verbal speech with
a series of little noises lifting off
The house's plastic roof a tiny sculpted
Pizza slipped off the tiles so we built
this a while ago during the peak of the
show's popularity Clarin explained it's
a doll's house the doll's inside her
somewhat alive as you can see but
they're always acting out the plot of
Breaking Bad scene by scene in broadcast
order sure enough one of the Dolls was a
miniature bald-headed Walter White
making some little squeaks that sounded
like it was saying I am the one who
knocks Breaking Bad has had a major
Resurgence in mean culture lately so
this could be a viable product one of
the other board members chimed in right
exactly Claire and smiled nervously uh
of course we'd have to sort out a
licensing agreement with AMC otherwise
we might get sued returning to their
seat Clarin trailed off hoping someone
else would step in to fill the latest
bout of uncomfortable silence wiping a
bead of sweat from his brow a Mr Ash
took the floor his assistant wheeling in
a projector and hooking it up to a
laptop the rest of the executives
couldn't hear the imaginary building
drum roll in Ash's head as he walked up
and began to play a video clip my fellow
board members he announced with a well
rehearsed beaming Smile as interesting
as some of these other pitches have been
I believe I may well have something
truly special to show you behold the
doctor wondertainment zumatron pedal car
through the projector the video showed a
large plastic toy car with a crash test
dummy sitting in it it gradually began
building up speed at an impressive rate
for an outdoor toy the sumatron was
whipping around an indoor testing track
faster and faster until it was little
more than a blur a speeding ring of
constant motion the board could just
make out the dummy's arms flailing
limply thanks to the sheer G-Force I'm
almost afraid to ask Mr Glenridge
cleared his throat and spoke up but
exactly how fast does that thing go I'm
very glad you asked Mr Ash replied
excitedly it can reach up to Mach 6 with
just an average amount of pedals per
second or PPS if you will but surely
that's dangerous mixclaren queried I
mean an object of that size moving six
times the speed of sound that low to the
ground I won't deny there have been a
few um let's call them teething problems
Ash admitted almost on cue the video
showed a wondertainment Enterprises
worker stepping accidentally into the
path of the speeding pedal car only to
vanish in a split second as it whized by
the car shot into and then through a
nearby wall you have anything else Mr
Ash Dr wondertainment asked impatiently
from their chair I um well I he
stammered rummaging through some papers
um in a similar vein we also developed
an electric scooter you know the like
those bird ones you see people riding
around on a lot doesn't go quite as fast
as the zumatron so that could
potentially be safer marginally I meant
to say marginally safer well that's the
catch with this one the board member
asked their exasperation obvious in
their tone it's probably better if I
just show you Mr ash side he pressed
play on another testing clip where in a
wondertainment employee stood atop their
scooter at first it seemed to be moving
normally that is until the camera
filming had zoomed out the employee and
the scooter were floating several feet
in the air we're uh we're still waiting
for that staff member to return from
their Journey he said sheepishly I'll
just sit back down what if we made a
yo-yo out of lasagna Mr Glenridge asked
the rest of the board all turned to look
at him confused before he receded in
this chair out of embarrassment fiddling
with his starving Tamagotchi in the
hopes that the next outlandish toy idea
would make everyone forget what he had
just said luckily enough one of the
execs Miss Stevenson opened up her
briefcase and produced a brightly
colored stuffed bear if I might bring us
back to basics she announced or bear six
if you pardon the pun we won't Dr
wondertainment said bluntly oh well um
allow me to introduce the doesn't care
bear Stevenson forced a smile then
handed the bear to the nearest board
member what am I supposed to do with
this Mr Ash ass confused just press the
stomach Miss Stevenson urged giving him
a wide-eyed glare as if to say either
work with me here or please help doing
as instructed Ash gave the doesn't care
bear a gentle squeeze activating a voice
box somewhere inside it wow Marlon your
surgeon really conned you for those hair
plugs the bear sneered cruelly Mr Ash
instinctively reached up to his forehead
where his hairline had been noticeably
receding until only a few months ago but
he'd never told anyone about his
transplant in truth it was something he
felt pretty insecure about I I don't
know what it meant by that Mr Ash
protested playing it off with a
half-hearted chuckle darn thing must be
defective not as defective as your scalp
Marlon the bear gave another callus jeer
did you seriously think that looked
realistic nobody's hairline is that
ruler straight not naturally anyway
maybe if you've been a baker like your
dad wanted you to you could have avoided
all the stress that made you lose your
hair in the first place then again you
were never that good of a son to him
anyway how in the hell dude turn this
awful thing off Mr Ash asked frantically
holding back tears isn't it great miss
Stevenson said forcing a toothy grin
imagine how great it would be for
boosting kids confidence by honing in on
their worst insecurities mixclaren
raised an eyebrow presenting them was
something they don't like about
themselves will challenge them to
improve on it Stevenson argued in an
unjustly condescending voice that's just
basic reverse psychology Deborah taking
a one-day course doesn't make you a
clinical psychiatrist that doesn't care
bear retorted you know you really aren't
as smart as you want people to think you
are how about a modern update of an old
classic Mr Jeffries an older executive
spoke up excitedly setting up something
on the table in front of him it was a
pair of foldable playing boards with a
collection of tiny ships each one a
different size and shape mix Clarin if
you'd be so kind he said passing them
one half of the board game that's just
Battleship Stevenson retorted stuffing
the abrasive bear back into her
briefcase ah but wait Mr Jeffries
replied Jovi Lee finished placing his
miniature boats now then give me a
coordinate ah B6 Clarence said Direct
Hit Jeffries clapped his hands excitedly
it was then that everyone noticed a tiny
streak of smoke shooting up from one of
the ship tips on Clarence board glowing
its sword directly upwards leaving a
trail behind it climbing through the air
over the table then once it was above Mr
Jeffrey's board the little glowing
projectile began to plummet straight
back down at once the board members all
realized it was a miniature missile some
of them urgently ducking under their
desks before it struck its Target a
small explosion erupted on Mr Jeffrey's
board punctuated by a miniature Fireball
and cloud of black smoke that wafted up
only to be sucked into the boardroom's
air purifier from the battleship that
had just been hit with shrunken Ordnance
the wondertainment execs could hear some
tiny barely audible voices they were
screaming and shouting in a state of
panic mayday mayday and Abandoned Ship
Swim free lives were the only words
anyone could clearly decipher Battleship
extreme Edition Mr Jeffries announced
proudly with a chuckle met with looks of
concern from the board members brave
enough to sit back down in their chairs
while we're on the topic of games Mick's
Clarence broke up again I did did have
this they produced a handheld video game
player the kind that only featured one
classic title fortunately the particular
title was Pac-Man the distinctive music
and flapping sound of the titular
character's mouth instantly recognizable
even to the youngest members of the
wondertainment Enterprises board come on
K one of the executive side we're all
waiting to hear the catch ah it's um
this one's actually pretty horrible they
admitted handing the game across the
table to Mr Glenridge seemingly happy to
be free from the tamagotchi's please for
food he began absent-mindedly playing
Pac-Man I mean and handles well he
observed guiding the yellow mouth
flapping icon around the maze avoiding
multi-colored ghosts as he chomped down
on any dots in his path it's quite a
throwback too Hades Nostalgia is still
hot right now isn't it oh power capsule
Mr Glenridge hit the corresponding
buttons to lead Pac-Man towards the
larger dot which granted them a power-up
ability to eat the ghosts that were
patrolling the maze tapping away with
both thumbs he got Pac-Man to follow in
the path of one of the ghosts but then
the handheld game started screaming
really
treat a tinny 8-bit voice ma Mr
Glenridge face went pale drained of all
color as he stared horrified at the game
in his hands Pac-Man kept following the
path of the fleeing ghost gaining on it
the closer he got the louder the
compressed screaming got Billy stop
don't let him eat me please
sure enough Pac-Man caught up with a
ghost and kept up his Perpetual chomping
as the ghost was eaten in the game the
built-in speaker played the
blood-curdling cries of Mr glenridge's
mother over the classic theme music
silently with a look of pure shock on
his face Glenridge put the game down on
the desk so yeah there's that Clarin
said awkwardly a Pac-Man game with the
souls of dead relatives trapped inside
these toys are all well perfectly
useless let's be honest the good doctor
erupted are you forgetting we have the
SCP Foundation breathing down on necks
surely any one of these Abominations
would have them poking around and
investigating us even more how about
this one of the execs interrupted
picture Monopoly but site 19 Edition we
could really get our own back on the
foundation exposed where the anomalies
are kept just generally cause some
trouble for them oh the playing pieces
could be some of the things they have in
containment another joined in instead of
the shoe the car and the iron we might
have an anomalous shoe car and iron and
being sent to jail in the game would
turn a player into a member of their
d-class personnel the first board member
replied enough the doctor's booming
voice silenced the whole room that is
without a doubt one of the most absurdly
stupid ideas I have heard in the history
of this company with respect somebody
spoke up I think you're all overthinking
this one of the board members who had
been sat at the furthest end of the
table keeping quiet throughout the rest
of the farcical presentations suddenly
stood up adjusting his time he addressed
his fellow entertainment Executives
doctor you'd like our apologies your
company to uphold its core purpose to
make toys and Reach people all over the
globe he stated and as a healthy added
bonus you'd like to stick it to those
killjoys over at the SCP Foundation too
so why don't we do something that will
cover all those bases that's what we've
all been trying to do Glenridge
protested like I said you're
overthinking it the exec replied let me
show you some
casually he produced a stylized plush
the group leaned in astonished to see it
resembled as cp049 better known as the
plague doctor we make plushies the board
member paused for dramatic effect of the
foundation's scps very intriguing Dr
wondertainment declared finally turning
their chair around to Face Forward
examining the plague doctor plush in
their gloved hand anyone who types
scpswag.com into their search engine of
choice will find high quality plushies
of some of the SCP foundation's most
beloved anomalies there was a torturous
pause the members of The Boardroom could
barely breathe as Dr wondertainment Rose
to his feet and began to clap you son of
a [ __ ] I'm in now go and check out
scp-001 a simple toy maker my favorite
episode and all the little misters
explained for more of the wondrous world
of doctor wondertainment